جريمه بشعه في مصر قتل زوجته وارسل سلفي
مع جثتها لاهلها
وعرض مقابلتان ناريتان لهاري المستمر
فيهما بمسلسل الفضائح ومغرضون الامير فقد
عقله
مسؤولا فرنسيه على الاعتذار من زين الدين
زيدان بعد تصريحات المسيئه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
اهلا فيكم مشاهدينا اذا الليله كانت بشعه
وحزينه جدا على اهالي الدقهليه في مصر
بسبب جريمه شنيعه جدا انتشرت اخبارها
عربيا وعلى كل المنصات الجنين ارتكبها
الزوج ذبح زوجته وتصور مع الجثه سيلفي
وارسلها لعائلتها بحسب وسائل الاعلام ومن
بعدها اخرجي مقاطع نشرها على حساباته
بطالب بحضور الاعلام لحتى يخبرهم بشو صار
يا جماعه اهل الخير انا مش هانزل من فوق
من شقتي بعيالي لما يجي حد من القنوات
يصور معي ويعرف قضيتي ويعرف ايه اللي
وصلنا لكده ويعرف انا في الوضع ده ليه
كل ده من اجل ثلاث بنات نفسي اكون معهم في
الدنيا ثلاث بنات بتمنى ان اكون معهم في
الدنيا
الفيديو اللي شفته مشاهدينا نشره القاتل
نفسه زي ما قلنا وهو لشاب اسمه حماده
العجوز متزوج من زينب اللي كان عمرها 26
سنه لديهم معا ثلاث بنات اكبرهم تسع سنوات
واصغرهم ثلاث سنوات الزوج والزوجه منفصلين
من ثلاث سنوات والصدمه كانت لما تبين انه
زينب كان منفصله او كانت منفصله عن القاتل
ورجعت له من اسبوع فقط بعد وسطات وتدخلات
وجهات الزوج لم ينشر فقط الفيديو اللي
شاهدنا لكن ايضا في مقطع اكثر بشاعه
ظهر وخلف وبناته وهو محتجازهم ومهدد
بقتلهم وقال انه زوجته كانت بتخطت لقتله
في تلك الليله بالتعاون مع شخص اخر
حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل في كل واحد شارك انه بعدنا عن
اطفال زي دي حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل حسبي
الله ونعم الوكيل في الظالم اللي كان
حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل في الظالم اللي كان
جاي يشاركها في قتل النهارده وعايز يبعدنا
عن عيالي حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل والله
وبعدين
المصريه في بيان القبض على الزوج وكشفت
التفاصيل قالت انه الاجهزه الامنيه سيطره
طبعا هو كان محتجز بناته في بلكونه وهدد
بقتلهم وقال انه تعدى على زوجته بسبب
خلافات زوجه
طبعا الشرطه
في الرقبه والسلاح الابيض ايضا المستخدم
في الجريمه
معنى مشاهدينا من الدقهليه ابراهيم فرج
ناصف والد الضحيه زينب وسامح سمير محامي
العائله اهلا فيكم معنا في تفاعلكم بدايه
ببدا معكم استاذ ابراهيم تعزينا الحاره
طبعا على فقدان زينب جريمه بشعه جدا واحنا
متفاهمين طبعا ظروف العائله وموقفكم الان
ولكن حابين نفهم الحكايه من الاول ايه
اللي حصل بالضبط هي زينب كانت منفصله عنه
اللي يعني رجعها له بعد قبل اسبوع تقريبا
بعد ثلاث سنوات من الانفصال
لا ده اللي حصل جوز ايه مطلقه قبل ما يمشي
قعد سنه ونصف من السعوديه
جاب رجاله
رحت يوم جاء يوم الاثنين قلت له خلاص يا
حماده عشان خاطر الثلاث بنات
وامراتك
حد يضحك علينا قال لك خلاص يابا يعني
طول ما حضن واحد غير جوزي
عشرين جوازي
عن جوزك واولاد الثلاث بنات
اتفضلوا اثنين هناك واحد
الاربعاء والخميس والجمعه يروحوا الجمعه
اخر النهار ثلاث ايام
ايه اللي خلاه يعمل اللي عمله ويقتل زينب
هو بيقول بانه هي كانت متفقه مع حد عشان
تتخلص منه الكلام ده
واخواته اكثر من 20 نفر من تيري انا من
قريه قريه اسمها
مركز نبروه
وجم بدل الواحد بدل المره 3 4 5
بتلفت لقيت واحده جايه بتقول ايه يا صقر
يا ابراهيم يا مش عارف ايه يا اولاد انتم
ما ضبطتوش الفيديو قلت لهم لا ما شفتوش
الفيديو
مع الاستاذ سامح استاذ سامح طبعا تم
اعتقال
الجاني
لوين وصلت التحقيقات وهل هناك اي معلومات
حول شو الدافع للجريمه همم يعني اذا كان
طبعا اهل الضحيه عم بيقولوا يعني هذا
الكلام عن عشان تتخلص منه مع اي شخص اخر
عاري عن الصحه
لا طبعا سياده الكوارع ارحب بحضرتك
والقناه العربيه
وحب اوضح نقاط
التحقيقات النيابه نفسها يعني
اصدق ما يقال
طبعا الكلام ده عادي جدا من الصحه اولا
الولد ده كان في كامل قوات العقليه الولد
ده كان مدبر مخطط
وعازم النيه وفي ادله بتاكد كده وده اللي
نسبته قدام النيابه العامه نيابه طلخا
سيادتك
القصه دلوقت اللي هي البنت اللي الله
يرحمها زينب
[موسيقى]
كانت منفصله عن زوجها سنه ونصف ولا سنتين
دخلت في سنتين
التالي
بنت حسنه السير والسلوك
ما بتطلعش بره بيتها اساسا كل همام
ثلاث بنات عندها ثلاث بنات
او الدافع قيل بانه كان تحت تاثير
المخدرات هل تحقيق ذلك
لا لسه طبعا التحقيقات لان طبعا المتهم
بيتعرض على الطب الشرعي وبيتم تحليله
بنسبه التحليلات اذا كان تحت تاثير المخدر
ولا لا بس انا عايز اقول لسيادتك حاجه من
الفيديوهات اللي سيادتك عرضتيها من شويه
فيديوهات من النظر اليها بالعين المجرده
بيبين ان الشخص مدرك
وعارف هو بيعمل ايه كويس شخص طبيعي جدا
يعني
استاذ ابراهيم هو يعني
يبدو انه شخص طبيعي ولكن في ذات الوقت
الافعال لا تنوم على انه شخص طبيعي طيب
استاذ ابراهيم انا بس بدي اسالك قبل ما
ننهي همم كان في حديث كثير عن انه هو مش
بس نشر هذول الفيديوهات اللي نشرها مش بس
نشر فيديوهات على حساباته ولكن بعثت لك
انت شخصيا الفيديو للاسف يعني متصور هو
سلفي مع جثه زينب مضبوط الكلام ده بعث لك
فيديو هو
ايوه بقى كله
الفيديو اهو اه يعني هو نشر على حساباتهم
استاذ ابراهيم
وقلع بدل العريس بيت عريس
بيت عريس قالت انا عمري يابا انا موجود يا
بت خلاص اقعدي مع التلج
وكانت رايحه فرحانه ابوك اخذ البنت يوم
الاربعاء
الخميس الخميس والجمعه
يوم الاحد
اتمنى
تحقيق العداله اكيد استاذ ابراهيم زينب
يرجع باذن
ما في كلام حكى يعني
الله يرحمها استاذ ابراهيم ويصبركم يا رب
سامح سمير محامي العائله شكرا
مشاهدينا كاميرا تفاعلكم كانت في موقع
الجريمه وسمعت لبعض الجيران جيران الضحيه
خلونا نتابع
نا نتكلم
عشان خاطر اولادك لو لمده ترجعي عشان خاطر
ربنا
عباره عن ايه هل هو
بيشرب وهي معترض بيشرب مخدراتي رجع بقى له
اربع ايام من يوم الاربعاء وهي راجعه
رجعت في الاخ الن- وهي على السرير ذبحها
ايه السبب بقى الله اعلم السبب ايه واحده
راجعه بقى لها اربع ايام في الفيديو بتاعه
اللي هيتكلم انه يتعاطه او ناحيه المخدرات
استحاله تكون رجل الفيديو كويس تلاقوه
بيتكلم بمنتهى العقلانيه
[موسيقى]
المشاهدين مثل ما هو متوقع اول مجموعه من
المقابلات للامير هاري للترويج لكتاب
مذكراته قلبت الدنيا مذكرات الامير مقرر
انها تطرح رسميا غدا في عشرين يناير لكنها
تسربت وعرضت للبيع مبكرا في اسبانيا وفي
اطار الترويج لها اه لانها على المجموعه
من المقابلات المنتظره للامير وعرض منها
بالفعل حتى الان مقابله ثاني
البريطانيه والثانيه مع السكس
ما هو متوقع المقابلات حملت مجموعه قنابل
جديده من الاتهامات والتصريحات الموجهات
ضد العائله الملكيه الاولى المقابلات التي
عرضت كانت مع اي تي في وابرز ما حملت من
تصريحات كان التاريخ
اعضاء من العائله المالكه تعاملت مع
الشيطان بحسب وصفه ويقصد طبعا بهذا
الموضوع الصحفي الصفراء وهذا الحكي لتحسين
سمعتهم على حساب سمعته هو وزوجته ايضا
تحدث عن غروب ومع اسرته الى الولايات
المتحده وقال انه كان خوفا على حياته
حياتهم قال انه تصرفات العائله في جنازه
جدته الملكه التي نزلت كانت مروعه
ورغم كل هذا قال الامير هاري انه يرغب في
المصالحه مفتوح لكن والده شقيقه والعائله
هم اللي لم يظهروا اي رغبه في التصالح
عموما كثير من قيل في مقابله اي تي في
يتكرر كمان في مقابله سكس بنات ايضا في
وثائقي همم ايضا اتكرر في وثائقي نتفلك
مؤخرا الامير تحدث مجددا عن تعاون القصر
مع الصحفي الصفراء لا نقل اخبار وقصص غير
حقيقيه عنه وعن زوجته
انا تعبان شويه
ماي واي
[موسيقى]
من المفاجات التي تفجرها الحري كمان في
مقابل
العائله مسؤوليه وصول متاخرا لبلمورو عند
وفاه جدته قال انه لم تتم دعوته للسفر
معهم الى هناك هاري كمان اعترف ايضا
بتعطيل المخدرات لتجاوز حزن على والدته
وقال ايضا انه خدمته في سلاح الجو في
افغانستان ساعده على تخطي الازمه امريكا
في مذكرات واتحدث كمان عن تعطيل المخدرات
في شبابه وايضا عن قتله 25 من المسلحين
طالبان في افغانستان خدمته هناك هاري في
مقابله سكس ايضا كامله زوجته
وصفها بشريره والخطيره
حقيقه مسلسل غير منتهي او في الحقيقه هو
مسلسل غير منتهي ولا يبدو انه راح ينتهي
قريبا كل هذه التصريحات الجداليه
والتهامات والادراما يضاف اليها ما ورد في
مذكراته واللي لا تقل جدليه والدراما
وتناولناها احنا تفصيلا امس يعني تفاصيل
عن فقدانها دريته على يد امراه بتكبره سنا
في حقل وكلام كمان عن مشاهد الحميميه
اثناء اعمالها كممثله وخناقه مع اخوه
الامير وليام ضربوا خلالها وغيرها كمان من
الفضائيه
في الكتاب تطرق ايضا فضيحه
تورط عمو الاميره في قضيه اعتداء جنسي تم
تسميتها لاحقا وبهذا اصبح هو اول عضو في
العائله المالكي يعلق على القضيه امام كل
هذه الصراحه من يعني من غير المستغرب انه
يسيطر الموضوع على الترند العالمي وبيوقت
في طاعته في كبير لكن المقابلات والمذكرات
على الاقل الى الانش علىته كمان عرضه
للكثير من الانت وحتى الهاشتاج الاكثر
تداولا عالميا هو برنس
وترجمته الامير هاري اصيب بالجنون
الفرنسي زين الدين زيدان من اساطير كره
القدم كان كلاعب ومن بعدها كمدرب ومع انه
ما بيدرب اي فريق او منتخب من كذا سنه لكن
اسمه من امبارح ترند حول العالم والسبب هي
تصريحات مسيئه ليست تصريحات خارجه منه
ولكن عنه صاحب التصريحات هو رئيس الاتحاد
الفرنسي لكره القدم
خلال مقابله اذاعيه مع راديو ايرسين
سبورتس فالمضيع سال رئيس الاتحاد عن تمديد
عقده مع مدرب المنتخب
انه كان متوقع انه يستلم زيدان التدريب
بدل عنه فكان الرد من الرئيس الاتحاد
والتفصيل كالتالي انا لا ابالي بزيدان
يمكنه الذهاب الى اي مكان يريد وهو ليس من
ضمن عمله لم التقي به ونحن لم نفكر ابدا
في الانفصال عن المدرب الحالي يمكن او
يمكن
ان الذهاب حيث يريد وهذه الجمله بصراحه
قالها لما سال عن احتمال تدريب زيدان
لمنتخب البرازيل
وزاد رئيس الاتحاد وقال هل حاول زيدان
الاتصال به بالتاكيد لا حتى انني لن امسك
الهاتف لارد عليها
تصريحات حتى قلبت الدنيا وانتفض العالم
لدفاع كله الى جانب زيدان ومن كل جهه نادي
ريال مدريد اللي دربو زيدان سنوات قصده
بيان وصف خلاله وتعليقات بالمؤسسه حيل احد
اكبر اساطير الرياضه في العالم رئيس
الاتحاد بعدم احترام احدى اكثر الشخصيات
اثاره للاعجاب حول العالم وانه زين الدين
زيدان يجسد قيم الرياضه واثبتها الشيخ
خلال مسيرته الاحترافيه كلاعب ومدرب ايضا
وزيره الرياضه الفرنسيه بتغريده قالت فيها
انه تصريحات بتسيء ليس فقط اسطوره القدم
والرياضه بل للجميع واعتذرت من زيدان على
اليسار على الصعيد الشخصي كمان طلع
المهاجم الفرنسيه
ومن بعد كل الضغوطات انتخابات رئيس
الاتحاد الفرنسي من ساعات طلع واعتذر في
بيان وتعليقاته كانت سخيفه وانه لا تعبر
عن اراء ولا تقديره لزيدان كلاعب ومدرب ام
زيدان مشاهدينا فمن اول القصه وملتزم
الصمت وما علق اطلاقا ختام تفاعلكم الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]